with brexit just around the corner and
Euroskeptic parties gaining momentum in
the EU French president Emmanuel macron
has outlined his grand vision of a
reformed Europe his open letter features
a number of ambitious plans shallow
Dubinski has more
well this letter has been outlined to
citizens of Europe and it's been
published in newspapers in the 28 member
states of the European Union
this comes as many centrist politicians
are fearing that they're not going to do
as well in the forthcoming European
elections as we see in polls suggesting
that nationalist and populist parties
are likely to gain seats across Europe
in those forthcoming elections now Matt
corns outlining his vision a renascence
of Europe as he calls it but he also
outlined that there are threats to
Europe never since the Second World War
has Europe been so necessary and yet
never has Europe been in such a danger
he sees that danger as being twofold one
it's the Euroskeptic MPs Euroskeptic
politicians people who he's described as
exploiting public anger but it's not
just Euroskeptic politicians that he's
pointing the fingers at he's also
pointing the fingers towards those who
don't want to do anything who want the
status quo to remain as it is he says in
his letter and this is about people who
would be sleepwalking towards a
diminished Europe he also talks about
migration a very sticky issue for many
centrists and something that Europe has
been battling now with for the last few
years and he describes the need to set
out new rules for the borders of the
Schengen area and also a border force of
police that all of Europe works towards
no community can create a sense of
belonging if it does not have protected
territorial limits we therefore need to
rethink the Schengen area all those who
want to be part of it should comply with
obligations of responsibilities
stringent border controls and solidarity
a single asylum policy with common
acceptance and refusal rules one of the
other things he talked about was
interference and meddling suggesting
that foreign powers
shouldn't be able to finance parties in
Europe I propose the creation of a
European Agency for the protection of
democracies to provide each EU member
state with European experts to protect
their election process against
cyberattacks and manipulation so what's
the reaction been well across Europe
many politicians have slapped macron on
the back for outlining his vision but
here in France there has been a lot of
criticism from opposition politicians
some describe him as being like the
character dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
flip-flopping on his policies being all
about the words and not being about the
substance this is of course not the
first time we've heard some of these
ideas from makkhan since he took office
back in 2017 and there's been criticism
of social media the fact that president
Matt God while outlining this grand
vision this Renaissance of Europe is
really struggling to control many of the
things that are happening here in France
take the yellow vest protest this is an
anti-government movement that's been
going on now for more than three months
16 consecutive Saturdays of protests
that people have described at times as
being some of the worst in the last 50
years here in France and it's not just
the yellow vest protest we're seeing
protests by students protests by
teachers protests by workers from the
medical fields all unhappy with the
reforms that Matt Gaughan has been
trying to push through since his
election and many people saying you know
if you can't sort out things in your own
country how can you then decide to
outline what you think Europe should be
doing in future some suggesting that the
president is trying to bite off more
than he can chew
you